[Music]
hello and welcome
today we'll be discussing how to
optimize your data ingestion
I'm way a Google Cloud developer
Advocate I've been fortunate enough to
work with some of the largest technology
companies in the world under data
engineering needs
we have a special guest today from
Mercado Libre to tell us about how and
why they move from Pulsar to Google
Cloud Pub sub
I'm joined by Andres and Shane Andres
would you please introduce yourself
for about nine years
hey everyone I'm Shane glass and I'm a
developer advocate here at Google Cloud
today we'll be going through the data
ingestion migration Journey that
McCarter Libre embarked on Andres were
first introduce the data ingestion
challenge at Mercado Libre then he'll
show us how and why they decided to move
the cloud Pub sub
let's first talk a little bit about the
data ingestion and why it's such a
critical component in many businesses
today
when it comes down to it it really is an
evolution of a business question
analytics seeks to answer the question
what has happened often that question
probably included a negative event and
raise voices wondering why something bad
happened and how the organization can
keep it from happening again
what we're discussing today is primarily
focused on the step two what is
happening this fundamentally shifts the
focus from reactive to proactive
by enabling your business to be more
proactive it also opens the door for
future enablement of continuous
intelligence and understand what should
be happening
the first step of all of this is to have
a robust data ingestion framework or
getting the data in
Andres before we go any further could
you please tell us about about Mercado
Libre
is the largest e-commerce in Latin
America more than 75 million active
users increasing every year and our
company growing by twice a year over
year
we have built an ecosystem where each
element becomes stronger by relying
on others and that having the key to
growing so quickly
and when the business scale the
technology needs to scale
that's amazing can you share some
metrics about how big you've grown to
yeah we are in 18 different countries
with more than 250 million Newton Salt
per quarter with more than 34 000
employees and we have more than
12 000 Engineers working across four
major clouds
those Engineers are working with more
than
24 000 microservices running more than a
hundred thousand virtual machines these
are not small number at all to have this
scale we had built attractions to hide
this complexity or plug the teams
and some of the tools that you've built
are uh in-house are called Theory can
you tell us a little bit more about it
Fury is our is our platform as a service
that offer capabilities in the form of
software as a service each capability is
managed by teams with the expertise in
that particular feature
within our platform engineering teams
it's an extraction layer for all those
or in developers on top of the cloud
services
it has a lot of different capabilities
such changing ability to result traffic
observability and a lot of platform
services
a platform service
could be seen as an abstraction of a
particular product for example we
provide a key value storage service in
which we can
choose the specific engine without
impacting any user the platform team
will handle debugging details
each platform service team has the
responsibility to improve Brazilians
Keepsake cost increment and control the
respect like elastic scale observability
governance and evolution of their
products
this is the fury in a nutshell and what
each developer from our company see
every single day
so here they they can control and
monitor their micro services and related
products
most of our security offer is attracted
away from the underlying implementation
so developer work with these
abstractions because after that the
platform engineering team are the one
responsible for defining Direction
implementation for a game platform
service
an example of this is choosing between
using Google pops up or other product
for our polish subscriber solution
developer wants to experience any change
on their end
they only know that apologize
requirement service offering between
Fury not implementation details
this is especially important
during immigration initiative because it
gives us the capability to root traffic
seamlessly even across Cloud will change
on the fuel interface and client
applications only changing the internal
of the service
the important thing here is a structural
key to give us flexibility
if we didn't have them
anything will have been difficult to
adopt another immigration nearly
possible
what about your data ingestion service
could you tell us more about it
yes we call it BQ which is an
abstraction layer for our pollution and
subscription services
we have Apache Pulsa as a vacant service
behind it
and what kind of numbers were we looking
at to sustain a business such as yours
we have 1.5 gigabyte per second
going into our publisher and about four
gigabytes per second being filled out
I'll produce about 35 million messages
per minute and deliver about 85 million
percent
per minute
that's amazing thanks for sharing Let's
uh dive a little bit deeper into the
journey that took you from migrating to
Cloud Pub sub and share that experience
you definitely have the capabilities to
run your own data ingestion what spurred
McCarter Libre to migrate over from
postler to Pub sub
there were a lot of moving parts that we
need to manage and we were small team we
were completely upgrading and updating
to ensure we could sustain our group
keeping the software an infrastructure
up today was tedious
complex and error prone task
mostly every upgrade and more
information
infrastructure or cluster and more
infrastructure implies more operation
and overhead to keep them running their
problems
we have our 1500 intercept with more
than Jupiter white of thirsty certain
hour of that injection meets
and this infrastructure was static so we
had to replace one by one where it was
required
and some component we are sensitive to
this change sometimes we have to replace
multiple sentences in few hours in
critical cluster
funny times and we have to our provision
the stress capacity to ensure we could
handle bit burst so storage utilization
of the infrastructure was only
15 50 on average
another problem is that the nature of
our Venus has Cycles
as you can see here on the graph we have
a very clear pattern during the night
the user of EQ service is less than
three times the day usage
this means that our static
infrastructure
also under utilizer during those times
so win the VQ team solves an important
opportunity for improvement and decide
to release and establish a product in
the industry
focusing on
approach that would escape to meet our
needs
and also we still have the flexibility
we need
we also wanted something fully managed
so we could reduce the strain of the
team while also using TCO it was a must
to have future quality with our layout
solution
and one of the products that you
evaluated with Google Cloud Pub sub
we'll talk a little bit about the
features and benefits about Pub sub
later for now let's continue on to your
migration Journey
the architecture of EQ is represented by
digraph
a client application in the left side of
the image use a customer Decay and brief
message to a VQ topic the traffic goes
to a microservice that we call producer
API and this API type hides all
implementation detail of pulsar and on
the raw side of Pulsar backend we have
another micro service our push an API
that pulled message from subscription
and send every message to a consumer
application from another client using
HTTP post
note that this consumer application is a
clean HTTP server without any cartoon
APK or anything related to VQ
and the immigration to pubs up we we
have a brand new the user API that
talked to pops up and a new Pusher API
as well
in front of you of both the user API we
will the routing component that permits
handle traffic in a fine grinded way for
example we can route a work letter or
only root only one topic using a
strategy like traffic splitting to
select all in some percentage of it
another capability for the traffic
between our apis and Popstar is a
possibility to grow part of the traffic
through internet and the other one
through interconnect using Google
private service connect
this sounds like a great success were
there any insightful findings during
your journey that you'd like to
highlight for others
you could end up taking many shortcuts
while trying to move to at maximum speed
to gain interaction during immigration
some of this shortcut may be delaying
the creation of proper management and
Country component that simplify
operations
please don't while this may seem a gain
in the short term
it can be very risky and might cause
many unexpected problems during
migration
another one maintaining two again
simultaneously is actually
complex and introduce complications
be sure that you understand the
implication of that the benefit
outweighs the problems it is really
important to have dashboard to get
observabilities
when you are changing a lot of
configuration at the same time
also if we have this command line
interface to change configurations we
could have prevented many errors
stacking up
thanks for sharing all of that what were
some of the thoughts that you had as you
migrated from Pulsar to Pub sub
we will assume about the cost of moving
to a fully managed platform
we wanted a better solution but that
involves evaluating the cost as well
and by moving to Popstar we actually
found many cost benefits we had the
flexibility to pay only what we use
so we could scale as much as we need it
our team can also now focus on other
business priority rather than
infrastructure upkeep
and we also call our augmentation
windows
which were mostly at night because we
wanted to minimize the routine during
the day for the business
latency is another one our tool set
implementation has outstanding response
times the production times around four
milliseconds
we are concerned that
latency will be a mission issue when
moving to Pasta
we worked with the Google team to
minimize this and then with this heat
and operation latency but we managed to
keep it within our requirements
sometimes we have really high spike in
traffic and we need to make sure the
solution we choose could handle those
spices
as you can see here in the graph we stop
the video service for a couple of
minutes I start again in less than two
minutes all the traffic was sent to
power some without being issue
and this Spike was really big
sometimes we have use cases where a lot
of messages are filtered
by our Pusher API and using Pub sub
there is no visual scale in that field
trip
but for our previous architecture we
have to put a limit on filtering because
it has some of our infrastructure
component
this is one of my favorite graphs could
you please tell us what this means
the graph showed the number of alert
received by the BQ theme over time this
alert are very important to us because
they can affect the service so we treat
them with a very high priority
you switch over to pops up with a full
cutover on much of the year
um you can see the big drop
you don't call alert after we switch
over
there are some remaining of Learners
some new but we are working to reduce it
the importance in here is
the alerts are used a lot
less alerts is a great thing let you
focus on your work and not worry about
it all the time
data ingestion is only one step of the
data pipeline now I'll pass it over to
Shane to take a look at some of the
other pieces that complete the platform
thanks way there have been many attempts
to solve The Continuous intelligence
challenges but they never quite hit the
mark
most of them were server based which
either requires you to build capacity
that far exceeds your typical
utilization in Ricardo libre's case
their capacity was double their typical
utilization or risk business critical
workloads experiencing major bottlenecks
these streaming engines also didn't
scale so you continue to pay for
infrastructure that supports your Peak
traffic levels even when your customers
go to sleep
in contrast to early streaming engines
Google's Universal continuous
intelligence platform is built to
support modern workloads our platform is
elastic so it scales up or down without
manual engineering effort
it's integrated with our data Cloud to
unify access to resources you turn to to
run your business
and it ensures that you can focus on
driving value for your business rather
than managing infrastructure
but what does this architecture actually
look like
well we start with Pub sub our messaging
and event ingestion service
Pub sub is deeply integrated with
dataflow and continually adds convenient
messaging and event ingestion to all of
the continuous intelligence capabilities
Within dataflow
Pub sub enters the picture where a high
volume ingestion and message delivery
taper off and data flow
to make the continuous intelligence
offering truly Universal Pub sub brings
massive scale to both ingestion and
delivery of messages and it does so in a
publish And subscribe Paradigm which
makes continuous intelligence accessible
to anyone and anything
it's scalability Global availability and
deep integration with dataflow allows
you to capture any scale of events
without sacrificing delivery performance
and speaking of data flow it's our
highly automated and fully orchestrated
service that's the backbone of our
infrastructure and architecture here
continuous intelligence platforms that
meet the full set of requirements for
modern workloads can be really complex
as we've seen
dataflow simplifies this by abstracting
away the complexity of data pipeline
management while still providing
petabyte and exabyte scalability
and because data Engineers normally have
to spend a painfully large amount of
time fixing poorly constructed data
pipelines we have built self-healing
into the product
and ensures real time or just-in-time
responses to business events
dataflex dataflow comes with flexible
orchestration to help you handle an
ever-expanding number of data pipelines
and it's simple to combine and cost
optimize batch and streaming Pipelines
it's latency-based pricing makes
dataflow affordable for all data
Pipelines
but the true measure of a continuous
intelligence solution is not just the
speed at which it can stream data the
most important measure is the speed at
which it can analyze that data to
provide insights that can be used to
respond to business events
our continuous intelligence platform
handles this by integrating data flow
with bigquery a data warehouse product
that was also built with real-time
streaming intelligence in mind
bigquery was designed for Universal
analytics architected for Simplicity and
comes with built-in machine learning and
geospatial capabilities
it's also serverless so you don't have
to spend time managing infrastructure
but when really sets bigquery apart is
the streaming buffer on top of its
persistent storage
this allows you to process streaming
analytics at any scale even up to
billions of events per second
this means no matter what your use case
calls for bigquery is ready to support
it
back to you right
thanks Shane we also want to bring your
attention to the hack Fest which is a
free gcp sponsored Workshop customer
will be able to see their own use case
in a demo in a deep dive if you're
interested in taking advantage of this
Free Hack Fest please speak with your
Google Cloud sales representative
that's all for today Shane and I really
want to thank you Andres and Ricardo
Libre for sharing this insightful
Journey with us for the audience thank
you for listening bye for now
[Music]